(bright instrumental music)
- How can you optimize your health
in preparation for pregnancy?
Let's explore five steps you can take
when you're planning to get pregnant.
If you have any chronic
medical conditions,
including diabetes, high blood pressure,
thyroid conditions, or depression,
it's important to meet with
your primary care provider
or obstetrician before becoming pregnant.
It's vital to check that all medications
or supplements you are taking
are safe for pregnancy.
Excellent management of
diabetic blood sugars
before you are pregnant
is especially important
for the normal fetal development
in the first eight weeks of pregnancy.
If you've had prior complications
during pregnancies in the past,
it's also important to
discuss this ahead of time
with your obstetrician,
as there are often
interventions that may help
avoid these complications
in future pregnancies.
Preparing for pregnancy
is an important time
to reflect on alcohol,
caffeine, or marijuana use.
I recommend to my patients
wean down caffeine intake to less than
a 12 ounce cup of coffee daily
and eliminate alcohol and
marijuana or drug use completely.
This can be hard to do
and I strongly encourage
doing it before pregnancy,
as it may take some time to adjust.
Most women will be tested
to see if they are a carrier
for cystic fibrosis or
spinal muscular atrophy,
even without a family history.
Take the time to review
your family history
with your relatives to find out
if there is a known hereditary carrier
in your family tree or
that of your partner.
If so, it's advisable to
meet with a genetic counselor
to discuss further screening tests
prior to becoming pregnant.
Pregnancy is a marathon and
labor is a sprint at the end.
Working to ensure that
you are physically fit
entering pregnancy will improve
the health of the pregnancy,
ease of delivery and
your postpartum recovery.
Regular cardiovascular exercise
can and should be
continued during pregnancy,
as well as most other kinds of exercise.
If you are overweight, even
a 10% reduction in your BMI
can improve your pregnancy outcomes.
I recommend minimizing environmental
exposures in your home and work,
such as mercury, lead, pesticides,
air pollution, household
cleaning products,
plastics for food
storage that include BPA,
and infection risks such as exposure
to common childhood viruses.
Women who start prenatal
vitamins with folic acid
at least one month prior
to becoming pregnant
have a reduced risk of nausea
and vomiting during pregnancy.
Additionally, folic acid supplementation
of 400 micrograms daily is recommended
for reduction of spinal
cord malformation risk.
The neural tube is forming
in the first few months of pregnancy,
so starting before
you're actually pregnant
helps makes sure that your body is ready
to support this important
developmental time.
Finally, checking that you are up-to-date
on your vaccinations, such
as MMR or German measles,
and varicella or chicken pox
will help reduce the risk
of these dangerous infections
during your pregnancy.
These vaccines can not
be given during pregnancy
and should ideally be given
at least one month prior to conception.
Taking these steps will help
you to be better prepared
for the physical demands of pregnancy.
Your doctor is here to
support you on your journey
to a healthy pregnancy and a healthy baby.
(bright instrumental music)